[Musica]
abbiamo già ascoltato delle bellissime
storie ma io un po la grande opportunità
ogni giorno di lavorare con tante
organizzazioni e per questo vorrei
portarvi con me dentro delle altre
storie
sapevate che il primo sms è stato
mandato nel 92 e oggi il totale degli
sms scambiati supera quello della
popolazione mondiale che è pari più o
meno a 7 miliardi di persone
sapevate che la radio ci ha messo 38
anni per raggiungere una popolazione di
50 milioni di persone la tv 13 internet
quattro anni è uno dei social network
più famosi due anni
sapevate che una delle più utilizzate
piattaforme di streaming oggi nasce come
un attività di noleggio dvd e
videogiochi che gli utenti potevano
prenotare comodamente a casa via
internet per poi ricevere tramite
servizio postale e sapevate che il primo
e commerce di grandi marchi è italiano
ed è incluso tra gli unicorni ovvero le
start up tech che hanno raggiunto e
superato il valore di 5 miliardi insieme
a società della silicon valley e cinesi
sapevate che nel 2014 nasce la prima
fibra tessile realizzata a partire dalle
arance biodegradabile è sostenibile e
che dal 2018 è possibile misurare le
emozioni che clienti provano quando
entrano nel punto vendita così da poter
offrire soluzioni personalizzate
fate e migliorarne l'esperienza di
acquisto cosa hanno in comune queste
storie
io vedo delle novità vedo dei successi
c'è la tecnologia e ci sono delle
persone
il primo sms è stato ideato da due
ingegneri un tedesco un francese ed è
stato poi inviato per la prima volta
circa 52 anni dopo la radio è stata
inventata da marconi che di fatto ha
funto da apripista per le successive
invenzioni in primis la tv poi quello
che sarà internet e il mondo dei social
network dietro la più utilizzata
piattaforma di streaming oggi cioè lui
ride stings che dopo aver pagato una
penale di circa 40 dollari per aver
consegnato un film a noleggio in ritardo
decise che era arrivato il momento per
creare qualcosa di diverso e quindi crea
un attività prima di noleggio e che poi
diventa una piattaforma dove attraverso
un abbonamento mensile si possono
guardare tutti i film e tutte le sere tv
senza alcun limite
dietro al primo e commerce di grandi
marchi cioè lui federico marchetti che
decide di abbandonare una carriera
avviata in una banca di investimenti
perché voleva creare qualcosa di suo che
potesse unire il mondo dell'alta moda a
quello di internet e quel qualcosa
diventa prima una start up poi una
grande azienda e oggi fa parte di uno
dei più noti marchi del lusso dietro la
volontà di trasformare gli scarti delle
arance in una fibra tessile ci sono due
giovani donne siciliane a enrica adriana
che decidono di puntare su un problema
della zona ovvero gli scarti degli
agrumi e decidono di realizzare il primo
tessuto iper tecnologico oltre che è
sostenibile in grado di rilasciare delle
vitamine direttamente sulla pelle e
dietro un sistema in grado di misurare
le emozioni provate dei clienti
se lei ma ora mengoni ingegnere
industriale marchigiana che si trova a
riflettere durante un viaggio a cuba sul
fatto che oggi fosse possibile
scientificamente spiegare perché alcuni
prodotti vengono comprati dai clienti e
altri no e questa conversazione termina
in un sistema di intelligenza
artificiale che permette di analizzare
le emozioni dei clienti le loro
preferenze
così da proporre loro prodotti più
attraenti più in linea con le esigenze
di quel momento e in generale servizi
più idonei
tutte queste persone sono quelle che nel
linguaggio dell'innovazione vengono
chiamate degli early adopter ossia dei
pionieri delle persone che hanno avuto
un'idea ne hanno l'hanno sperimentata e
hanno provato ad aprirne la strada ma in
realtà queste persone non andò
semplicemente avuto un'idea di quelle se
ne sono tante e che queste persone sono
state in grado di portarla al mondo e
per farlo per crearsi il loro spazio
all'interno di un mondo complesso e
volatile come quello che viviamo noi
oggi queste persone hanno avuto nella
loro leadership due ingredienti
fondamentali il primo è la motivazione
daniel gol e mamma che uno studioso di
harvard dice l'unico tratto che accomuna
davvero tutti i leader e efficaci se mai
ne esiste uno è la motivazione una forma
di gestione del sé che ci consente di
mobilitare le nostre emozioni positive
per proiettarci verso un obiettivo
la motivazione è presente in tutti noi
ed è quella che ogni giorno ci fanno
andare avanti quello che facciamo il
nostro lavoro la nostra professione la
nostra attività quotidiana non è ben
visibile ma se ne scaveremo le troveremo
le tracce perché non è ben visibile
diverse psicologi paragonano la
motivazione ad una piramide in cui
raccontano che ogni individuo nello
svolgere il suo lavoro e per far sì che
ne sia soddisfatto di è importante che
risponda ad alcuni bisogni in primis ci
sono i bisogni di sicurezza che sono
quelli che hanno a che fare con la
sicurezza del lavoro che svolgiamo in
termini di ambiente di sicurezza in
termini di comfort dell'ambiente in cui
ci troviamo in termini di benessere
psicologico i bisogni di sicurezza di un
minatore saranno quelli di avere con sé
ogni giorno un casco di sicurezza di un
certo tipo che un attrezzatura di
sicurezza che gli permetteranno di
svolgere quotidianamente il suo lavoro
ma una volta che abbiamo soddisfatto i
nostri bisogni di sicurezza sul secondo
livello della piramide emergono degli
altri bisogni e sono i bisogni
relazionali che invece soddisfiamo
quando creiamo delle relazioni piacevoli
e positive sul luogo del lavoro sia con
colleghi che con il datore di lavoro e
queste sono estremamente importanti per
creare un buon clima in cui possiamo
venire apprezzati ed essere valorizzati
per il lavoro che svolgiamo ogni giorno
il nostro minatore che ha soddisfatto i
bisogni di sicurezza e vuole soddisfare
quelli relazionali proverà a creare
delle relazioni piacevoli sul lavoro
dove anche se non svolge un lavoro
fisicamente poco molto imponente proverà
in qualche modo a creare un ambiente di
lavoro in cui ogni giorno sarà felice di
andare lì perché sarà un po come essere
a casa una volta che abbiamo soddisfatto
i bisogni relazionali sull'ultimo
livello della piramide emergono i
bisogni di realizzazione di crescita che
sono quelli che invece soddisfiamo
quando ci sentiamo realizzati quando
abbiamo la percezione di utilizzare le
nostre competenze i nostri punti di
forza
ciò in cui siamo bravi questo livello
della piramide è estremamente importante
perché ci permette di capire cosa ci
muove davvero ogni giorno cosa ci motiva
verso quello che facciamo non è facile
da identificare perché è correlato alla
nostra natura interna di persone a dove
siamo cresciuti che contesti abbiamo
vissuto che percorso professionale
personale abbiamo fatto e se ci pensate
ognuno di noi si sente realizzato per
motivi diversi il nostro minatore che
vuole capire cosa lo farà sentire
realizzato ogni giorno non gli basterà
più avere un casco di sicurezza magari
il più all'avanguardia o un'attrezzatura
di sicurezza di un certo tipo ma dovrà
leggersi un po più in profondità e
magari capirà che a motivarlo e il fatto
che lui oggi stia svolgendo il lavoro
che prima di lui faceva il padre e prima
ancora il nonno e che quindi stia
portando avanti una tradizione di
famiglia oppure a motivarlo il fatto che
lui oggi o minatore ma perché
all'obiettivo di comprare la miniera un
giorno per farne qualcosa di su uomini
per capire in che direzione sta andando
la vostra di motivazione vi invito a
fare una riflessione che recentemente ho
fatto su di me provate a capire a quali
di questi bisogni voi oggi state
rispondendo con la vostra professione
con il vostro lavoro
se riuscite a soddisfare i primi due
livelli
provate a pensare a un episodio in cui
vi siete sentiti realmente soddisfatti
di aver me
in campo tutto ciò che vi caratterizzava
come persona nella vostra unicità circa
qualche mese fa mi è stata data la prima
la responsabilità del primo progetto
internazionale per l'organizzazione per
cui lavoro c'era dentro di me una forte
grinta una forte spinta ma anche una
paura di fallire e quello che ho provato
a fare è far emergere sempre di più
questa spinta che si muoveva
internamente dentro di me nonostante
tutti quelli che fossero gli imprevisti
quotidiani gli ostacoli e le difficoltà
che ci potessero essere e da questa
situazione insieme ad altri episodio ho
capito che io per sentirmi realizzata e
motivata avrò sempre bisogno di stimoli
continui di sfide e di elementi che
provano ad alzare la mia stich ella ma
abbiamo parlato di un secondo
ingrediente necessario alle nostre
storie iniziali ed è il modo in cui
affrontiamo non solo i successi ma anche
gli insuccessi le difficoltà i problemi
in una parola e il nostro mai infetta
karol beck che una professoressa
dell'università di stanford ha fatto un
esperimento con dei bambini proponendo
loro di risolvere dei problemi e molto
difficili alcuni hanno reagito in
maniera catastrofica rifiutandosi di
farlo perché quello secondo loro era un
modo di giudicare la loro intelligenza
altri hanno reagito in maniera
incredibilmente positiva mettendo già da
subito tanta volontà di provarci e
portare a termine quel problema questo
esperimento che poi è stato ripetuto su
degli adulti ci dice che oggi ci sono
due mine se principali per affrontare
gli ostacoli che quotidianamente
possiamo incontrare attraverso il fixed
ho mai in sé statico che tipico di chi
vede nei problemi nelle criticità delle
minacce
e per questo le dita piuttosto vede le
persone molto brave come un elemento di
competizione che potrebbe mettere in
luce le loro mancanze oppure attraverso
un gross mindset o mindset dinamico che
invece è tipico di chi abbraccia le
sfide anche se non è chiaro fin da
subito il modo in cui queste sfide
andranno affrontate piuttosto chi ha un
grosso mindset si circonda di esperti ed
i maestri del settore per apprenderne e
i loro segreti in modo da poterli
riapplicare e questo non è visto come un
elemento di competizione quanto come un
modo di apprendere continuamente per
entrambi i leader che abbiamo visto
prima avevano tutti una fortissima
motivazione e un mines dinamico che gli
ha permesso di far fronte
quotidianamente agli imprevisti e alle
difficoltà che hanno incontrato nel loro
percorso
nessuno lo dice ma il primo sms era un
sms realmente primordiale assolutamente
imperfetto che è stato mandato da un
computer a un cellulare solo tanti
tentativi dopo è diventato le sms che
noi conosciamo la piattaforma di
streaming oggi più utilizzata quando era
un corona start up si era proposta ad
uno dei grandi colossi del settore per
un valore economico molto altro
il grande colosso sapete che fece di
risen faccia e qualche anno dopo sempre
il grande colosso falli e quella che era
la start up con poca credibilità si è
affermata non solo come piattaforma di
streaming ma anche come casa produttrice
di serie tv e film
l'idea di un ecommerce di grandi marchi
nasce in un garage e diventa una startup
in anni molto bui anni di recessione
economica fine anni 90 e anni in cui
scoppiò la bolla di internet che fece sì
che nessuno più voleva investire nei
siti internet
l'idea di trasformare gli scarti delle
arance in tessuti all idea
a di misurare e analizzare le emozioni
dei clienti sono sicuramente due
progetti molto brillanti innovativi ma
che hanno richiesto e richiedono
tutt'oggi forti competenze
determinazione e risorse economiche non
solo da parte delle fondatrici e ma
anche delle loro famiglie nonché
aggiungerei una buona possibilità di
rischio
il mio invito per voi oggi è quello di
trovare la vostra di motivazione e di
allenare il vostro mindset per
apprendere continuamente di fronte a
quelli che sono le sfide e le difficoltà
che si possono incontrare quando si
decide di mettere in campo la propria
idea quindi crederci è importante ma non
basta
qualsiasi idea scegliamo di portare in
campo dalla più semplice alla più
incredibile è divergente è importante
farlo con le attitudini giuste e solo in
questo modo saremo in grado di aprirci
la strada di influenzare chi ci sta
intorno e di lasciare il segno
grazie
[Applauso]